[Music]
dearly beloved if anyone objects to this
marriage speak now or forever
hold where is
she there you are death to you father no
not you father you father oh
[__] we got what you doing this is much
worse than I thought that is a red one W
red one we should leave immediately an
will get over it we never like her
anyway so let's go congratulations to
the happy couple we are leaving Edie
YooHoo I'll be right with you right okay
you need to come out right now because I
am feeling super super vulnerable right
here FR just like you not for
long Eddie over here you need to come
out right now and I will let you eat
everybody you can eat them all apart
from him and the robe you cannot eat him
promise I
promise thank
you baby shut your MTH
mouth bar trouble
already time to die that's the spirit I
mean us we are going to
[Music]
die
wow fire and sound except without the
sound
better
[Music]
Hur
Mano
Mano you know how I Spent My Endless
days I spent them thinking about how you
only told one inside of the
[Music]
story you didn't write about the part
where Cletus was abused by mommy daddy
and
[Music]
Granny
[Applause]
[Music]
you didn't tell the world how he was a
scared little
boy that no one cared about
and no one came to
save
oh you never ask yourself
why that's bad
journalism Oh Happy
Days
I'm not a crazy
man but I am a finch for
one you're going to watch her die get up
I
[Music]
can't they're not
symbiotic get away from her shut up take
your hands off my
wife
they're not a
match we are that's right we
are together we
are the lethal
[Music]
protector
a
[Music]
let there be
courage I got you you
okay
father one of us must
die we need fire
or
[Applause]
sound
[Music]
holy
mackerel
he did not taste
[Music]
good